This episode is made possible by the realistic online game war thunder.
Check out this game through the link in the description below.
Go through that link and not only do you support this show that you also get a
free premium tank or an aircraft am three days of premium time as a bonus.
Let's get into it.
Okay.
From humble beginnings in rural Kansas,
Dwight David Eisenhower rose to become the most powerful man on the planet.
Before reaching that pinnacle,
he took charge of the airline defenses against the Nazi beast that was roaring
across Europe.
He led the world's victory,
becoming the undisputed man of the hour before leading America through the
fabulous fifties in today's biographics,
we learned about the 34th presidents of the United States,
Dwight Eisenhower.
Dwight David Eisenhower was born on the 14th of October,
1890 in Denison,
Texas.
His parents had lived in Abilene,
Kansas before his birth and it was there that they returned when he was just an
infant.
How's it trials?
He was involved in an accident,
so that cost his younger brother and I,
these are referred to this as an experience that taught him the need to be
protective of those who wants to him.
His.
Charles did that.
It was active,
eager,
and happy.
Sports played an important part in his developments.
Any excelled in baseball both in school and on a vacant lot next to his home.
Eisenhower said that not making the baseball team at west point was one of the
greatest disappointments of my life.
Maybe my greatest.
Yeah,
football.
It was his first love.
He made the varsity football team.
There's was a starter is running back and linebacker in 1912 when he tackled the
legendary Jim Thorpe of the Carlisle Indians.
Those sport was important.
The greatest staple of the Eisenhower family was religious observance.
The Bible was the guide to family life while speaking of himself in 1948
Eisenhower said he was one of the most deeply religious men I know though
unattached to any sector organization.
The Eisenhower home was also a home of patriotism as well as faith and one of
respect for the things of the mind,
competition and hard work were staples of the family routine.
Young Eisenhower worked during his spare time at a creamery while he was at
school.
Joy was 21 and a half to Abilene.
His destination was the military academy at West Point.
He graduated in 1915 and was commissioned as a second lieutenant of infantry.
He graduated in the middle of his class which came to be known as the class that
the stars fell on because 59 members eventually became general officers in the
summer of 1916 as a newly promoted first lieutenant stationed at Fort Sam
Houston,
Texas.
Dwight married Mami Geneva,
doubt of Denver.
She was his wife until Eisenhower,
his death in 1969 events in Europe.
They were forging a new way of life for the entire world.
World War One gave many officers their first experience of combat,
but young Eisenhower was not among them.
It brought him instead.
Commands have a training center at Gettysburg that he prepared troops of a new
tank coffer overseas deployment.
His performance one him the distinguished service medal.
He was stationed to Europe,
but before he could get there.
The word ended
in the late 90 twice.
He's after graduation from the command school and General Staff School.
You a Dwight d Eisenhower was assigned to France to prepare a guidebook on
American battlefields in Europe.
It was his first direct experience with that consonants.
In the 1930s he served under many talents and general such as John Jay Passion
and General Douglas Macarthur in the Philippines.
Eat worked for MacArthur for four years.
He was a commander in chief of the Philippine army and he was helping the
Commonwealth government work out a plan for its military defense.
Eisenhower had strong philosophical disagreements with Macarthur regarding the
leadership qualities that an American army officers should develop in his
subordinates.
The resulting animosity between Eisenhower and MacArthur.
It lasted for the rest of their lives or did bags of the United States in
December of 1939 Eisenhower,
it went to Fort Lewis,
Washington as an executive officer.
Of the 15th Infantry regiments.
In the dark spring of 1940 German armored divisions were crashing through
Holland and Belgium,
the Luftwaffe herb.
It was streaking its destruction through European skies.
France was being subjugated and Britain was left standing alone.
The United States had passed the selective service act to prepare for what
inevitably layer had.
Late in 1940 Eisenhower was made chief of staff of the Third Infantry Division,
pissed off work,
brought with it an assignment,
his chief of staff of the Ninth Army Corps.
In the summer of 1941 he became the chief of staff to cuddle.
Walter Kruger,
who's newly organized Third Army,
was preparing to participate in the most realistic war maneuvers is ever held by
American troops in these maneuvers over the Louisiana countryside.
Eisenhower's task was to work out a plan of defense against an invading mass
force.
Soon the maneuvers were over Ans Eisenhower.
It was promoted to brigadier general.
Then within a matter of days came the bombing of Pearl Harbor.
Although his supervisory abilities had been noticed before entry into World War
Two,
he had never held an active commands above a battalion and it was far from being
considered as a commander of major operations.
From almost this moment on the face of the nation and the feet of General d
Eisenhower would be an extra rubbly bound together called to Washington in the
first weeks after the warp.
Again,
Eisenhower went to work in the war plans office.
If the war department's one of the plans formulated during this time was the
central strategic determination to make an eventual attack across the English
Channel.
This was to be called the principal allied defensive effort.
Eisenhower's ability to rise to grieve responsibility brought him rapid
promotion
because an all ounce channel invasion would be impossible before 1944 and
because the need for offensive action was immediate.
In 1942 the allies undertook a combined operation under the command of General
Dwight d Eisenhower,
and that was the invasion of north Africa.
The minimum objective of this maneuver was to seize the ports between Casablanca
and Algiers along the rim of the North African coast.
Troops were put ashore in late November,
encountering resistance ranging from miles in Algiers do surprisingly stiff at
Casablanca.
The command,
his hope was to push quickly along the east of the Mediterranean and take
possession of the important posts of bezier and Tunis,
but a number of unfavorable circumstances including treacherous weather
conditions prompted the commander to hold off on his vital assault in the
spring.
However,
troops of Omar Bradley Second Score,
we're able to take Bessie a and at the same time Tunis fell to the British first
army were these victories.
Well,
that was the end of the Axis Empire in Africa.
The allied leaders and the men who had fought under them proudly commemorated
that victory,
one of the greatest products of the victory in the words,
as long as an hour he himself was the progress achieved in the welding of allied
unity and the establishment of a combat team that was already showing the
effects of a growing confidence amongst all its members.
The ends of this campaign,
it brought personal recognition.
Do Eisenhower throughout the world as him being a great leader.
The comadre himself interpreted this recognition is proof that free men can find
unity in victory,
even against seemingly invincible odds.
The next big campaign,
the invasion of Sicily brought further demonstration of this basic truth.
Allied troops took this vital rock in the summer of 1943 the affects of Sicily's
fall.
They were electric.
Italy surrendered the first of the access powers.
Do you capitulate now the ILO is prepared for what was to be the most fiercely
fought battle of the Mediterranean war.
The invasion of Italy itself.
It's Atlanta.
Through a miracle of courage and tenacity.
Lieutenant General Mark Clark's army established a beachhead overwhelming German
odds and taking Salono when's the vital port of Naples with these victories,
although heavy fighting an important battles did layer had the first major
objectives of the Italy campaign where accomplished ally forces were on European
soil and they were able to pin down German troops far from the scene of the
cross channel invasion,
which was planned for the following year.
President Roosevelt visited the combat area with General Eisenhower when he came
over.
For the Cairo in Tiran conferences.
Their agreement was once again establish that the principal allied effort would
be the invasion of Europe.
Shortly afterwards.
The man who would oversee this awesome undertaking was named and yes,
of course it was to be General Dwight David Eisenhower,
people throughout the free world.
We're now calling him the man of the hour.
The Supreme C'mon does orders from the general staff.
They were quite simple land on the coast of France and thereafter destroy the
German grounds forces.
Yeah.
Between the order and its execution.
Well,
there was certainly going to be a lot of efforts across the channel,
the heavy fortifications lining the coast of France,
bespoke,
the Nazis belief that they could simply push back and the invading army in
France alone at 58 German divisions,
we're waiting.
Preparing for this invasion was a job without let up incessant and realistic
training.
It was of paramount importance,
the challenges of morale,
the myriad details of coordination on every level.
All of these were simply overwhelming,
but through these tents months in the early part of 1944 the operations,
they continued finally after being postponed for one day because of weather
conditions.
The eve of the day of decision was,
it happens,
but commands have visited the airborne troops.
He would lead the invasion.
He later wrote,
I found the men in fine fessel joshing and assuring me that I had no cause for
worry.
Yes,
with the face of the war hanging in the balance,
Eisenhower felt the weight of the world on his shoulders.
So if you want all of the fun of Basser without,
you know it was a death and the horror and the objects awfulness,
why don't you should probably check out today's sponsor.
So wharf
up
well funds a is a realistic free to play military vehicle combat game war
thunder is available on PC ps four and Xbox one and I realized in recording this
ads that I don't know if it's a good thing,
but I have all of those platforms,
but the good news is you and you need one of them.
No need to purchase.
You can just download and get players.
Okay.
There are over 1,200 historically accurate vehicles all the way from the 1920s
to the 1990s there we'll carefully built and incredibly detailed and all of the
physics as well.
It's been sweated over so it's just very,
very good plus sound as good.
The music,
the sounds of facts,
it's all it's,
it's just a really excellent and like you can just jump in and play a quick
arcade game useful if you don't have much time or you could be a more realistic
version,
a challenging tactical situation or if you're hardcore you can try it simulator
and that's one I've never done because I don't like how he may ask wept over and
over again.
So join us on the battlefield for free.
Using the link below.
Doing that also supports this show and it gets you a free premium tank or
aircraft am three days of premium time as a bonus just for registering.
Let's get into the rest of them.
Moving.
The largest invasion force in the history of mankind to crossing the English
channel was a huge logistical challenge.
But the success of the enterprise,
it was largely dependence on something outside of Eisenhower's control and that
was the weather.
With the arrival of June,
there were just four days of potential good weather that Eisenhower could work
with the invasion.
It was planned for June the fifth but then bad weather rolled in on the fourth
with the expectation of more to come.
Eisenhower therefore considered per spooning the invasion on the other side of
the channel,
the Germans,
they were confident that there would be no invasion attempt to during the
inclement weather and it was at this point that the supreme allied commander how
to decision to make and finally he told his generals items and like it,
but we have to go on June the fifth at 9:45 PM he gave the order for the
landings to begin the following morning on June the sixth he said,
okay,
that's go.
He then addressed the salmon,
the sailors,
the troops of his command stating you are about to embark on the great crusade.
The eyes of the world are upon you and company with our brave allies and
brothers in arms on other fronts.
You will bring about the destruction of the German war machine and the
elimination of Nazi tyranny.
Your task will not be an easy one.
Your enemy is well trained and well equipped and battle hardened.
We will accept nothing less than full victory.
Good luck and let us besiege the best thing of all mighty God upon this great a
noble undertaking in the wallets.
If the supreme commands,
uh,
allied expeditionary force,
however,
was secrets at the following note dated June the fifth,
our landings in the shoebox Harv area have failed to gain a satisfactory
footballs and dive withdrawn the trips.
My decision to attack at this time and place was based upon the best information
available.
The troops,
the air in the Navy did all that.
The bravery and devotion to duty could do if any blame or fault attaches to the
attempts,
it is mine alone.
Those last two words,
mine alone.
They were underlined by Eisenhower at 3:00 AM on June the sixth President
Roosevelt was telephones with the information that operation overlord was
underway.
Just two days Nasssa Eisenhower was able to report to as president that the
operation was a success throughout d day.
June the six 156,115 men landed on the beaches of Normandy.
By the end of June in excess of eight 150,000 men along with 570,000 tons of
supplies and 148,000 vehicles,
they were on French soil.
The unstoppable march to Berlin was underway,
but also surrender came on May the seventh 1945 the Japanese followed just four
months later,
but only after the u s dropped two atomic bombs on their people.
Eisenhower was opposed to the dropping of the bombs after they were unleashed.
He said first the Japanese were ready to surrender and it wasn't necessary to
hit them with that awful thing.
Second,
I hated to see our country be the first to use central weapon
for Dwight Eisenhower.
That return from war was matched with the chairs of people from all over the
world and his own homelands.
A hero's welcome away.
Him,
despite his desire to enter retirement in America,
had other tasks waiting for their favorite soldier.
He succeeded.
General Marshall is the army's first post war chief of staff.
He expressed belief that one of the greatest pillars of world peace was a strong
United States and visited troops,
stations in various parts of the worlds,
and encouraged America's growing sense of global responsibility,
saying we must remain the first champions of those who seek peace in their own
lives and peace with their neighbors.
Finally,
on February the seventh 1948 the general from Abilene after 36 years of service
to his country,
left active military assignment.
He did not,
however,
leave active participation in the life of his nation.
He accepted an invitation from Columbia University to serve as president of that
institution at the time.
He thought that this would enable him to devote the remainder of his time on
earth to the challenges of education,
but events of the postwar wells they dictated.
Otherwise,
the urgent need for unity in the free world brought into being the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization or NATO.
It soon became clear that there was only one man who could make that vital and
complicated organization work,
and that was Eisenhower.
At the ends of 1950 he answered this country is called one small wins.
He again was on European soil to take supreme commands of the land,
the sea and the air force's.
If a grant is defensive alliance against the new threat of rising from the
Soviets who had previously been his nation's ally.
He had to create within the war where a European soul,
the will to defend itself so that freedom so dearly bought,
would not be lost for more than a year.
He labored diligently at his task of coalition when he turned over the reigns of
commands and General Matthew Ridgway,
the structure of military unity among the free nations upon which rested the
hope for continued peace.
It was well established
once again with the establishment of substantial victory behind him.
This might well have been the ends of Eisenhower's Public Korea.
Indeed,
this was the end of Eisenhower.
The soldier,
but it was just the beginning of Eisenhower,
the statesmen,
although we had shown no interest in politics,
Eisenhower was pursued as a presidential candidates by both the Republicans and
the Democrats.
This satisfied with the Democrats over their handling of the Korean War and
charges of corruption within the White House.
Eisenhower decided to join the Republican's and run for office.
He felt that the country needs attendant as he watched the country going in the
wrong direction.
He knew that he was the right man to get things back on track beyond just
military reputation.
Eisenhower was a very charismatic individual.
I like high quiz more than just a campaign slogan.
It was the true sentiment.
He was seen as a decent man who was willing to put himself forward to do what
was right for the country when what he truly deserved was to live out.
His final years in peace and seclusion is overwhelming popularity.
It catapulted him to the White House and while most people liked and trusted
[inaudible],
they weren't always sure that he was engaged in Oval Office fas.
A lot of people felt that it was simply presiding.
Over an administration and others weren't really making the decisions.
However,
although we had a reputation for being out to lunch,
every major policy decision really was his decision.
It was really him who was calling the shots.
In his first significant accomplishments,
Eisenhower brought about an end to the Korean War,
forging an armistice that is still in effect today.
While his military career has been built on waging war now,
it appeared that he was determined to use this presidency to pursue peace.
He began downsizing the military by spending less money on defense.
He believed that America could spend more on infrastructure and quality of life.
He went from orchestrating the largest military operation in history to pushing
the world's largest public works project through Congress.
The Federal Highway Act One Americans welcomes the change to their landscape.
They were not receptive to other changes to that culture.
One of the great unresolved issues after World War II was whether or not African
Americans would continue to be forced to live in a segregated society.
In 1954 the supreme court banned racial segregation in public schools and it's
landmark ruling of Brown versus board of Education.
Although Eisenhower had appointed Chief Justice Earl Warren,
the motivating force behind the revolutionary ruling,
Eisenhower publicly distanced himself from the decision considering it to be a
disruptive and inappropriate role for the federal governments in his eyes,
the country.
It was not yet ready for desegregation.
Words that he shared with Warren in privates,
they confirmed this.
Eisenhower asked him to consider the perspective of white parents in the deep
south.
These are not bad people.
The precedent set,
all they are concerned about is to see that this sweet little girls and not
required to sit in school alongside some big black box.
In 1954 after the French were defeated in Vietnam and the country was Spittin to
Eisenhower pledged his support for the pro western government of South Vietnam
over the communist run north.
It took a series of steps that were central to America's growing involvement in
Vietnam.
The most important was the creation of the Bank of Vietnam through which huge
sums of money was sent to South Vietnam.
For Aid and support under leadership America enjoyed peace and great prosperity
during his first time with the economy soaring.
He easily won reelection in 1956 and interesting note here is that during his
presidency,
Eisenhower was on the maiden flight of Air Force One which replaced the previous
presidential aircraft.
The Columbine traditionally second presidential Thames much tougher than the
first,
and this was certainly true for Eisenhower.
First,
he had health concerns suffering a heart attack in 1955 that's combined with his
aloof reactions,
do growing civil rights unrest made him seem rather weak.
Then came Sputnik,
the first satellite in space launched by the Soviets in 1957 Americans,
they became hysterical believing that there was a missile and GAF and the
Russians favor.
In 1959 Fidel Castro seize power in Cuba establishing a revolutionary regime
just 90 miles from Florida.
That was another sign that America was losing out to the Soviets.
That was now a feeling that communism was overwhelming America.
The grandfatherly image that Eisenhower had enjoyed was now seen as a bit of a
liability and his final address to the nation.
He spoke to the American people with unprecedented candor.
He warns that Americans must guard against the acquisition of unwarranted
influence by the military industrial complex for a military man,
yet alone,
the general who had been the supreme commander of the allied forces.
This was a stunning pronouncement,
the hero of World War II.
He wants it nothing more than to leave behind a presidential legacy of peace to
him,
a man who had fought and seen firsthand the destruction of war combat.
It always had to be the very last resort
in accordance with the 22nd amendment to the u s constitution.
Eisenhower was the first president to be affected by the prohibition on running
for a third time following the end of his second term in January of 1961 his
commission as a five star general was reinstated and he took up residence to a
working farm opposite the Getty's filled battlefield and Pennsylvania.
Throughout the 1960s Eisenhower gave his influential support to a number of
Republican politicians,
including Barry Goldwater in Richard Nixon.
When Nixon won the presidency in 1968 Eisenhower comments is that it was a day
for rejoicing Eisenhower Diet on March the 28th 1969 of congestive heart
failure.
He was 78 years of age.
He was eulogized by President Nixon with the following words.
Some men are considered great because they lead great armies,
or they lead powerful nations.
For eight years now,
Dwight Eisenhower has neither commands and Denomie nor led the nation,
and yet he remains through his final days,
the world's most admired and respected man,
truly the first citizen of the world.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
So subscribe.
You'll find out about all of those.
Also,
if you leave with something else to watch,
why not check out my other channel called today,
I found out,
and you'll find a link to that below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
[inaudible] yeah.